let's talk about dr. Anthony foutch II
dr. Anthony foul he has to be very
careful in his role on the White House
coronavirus task force in his role as
the top infectious disease doctor in the
United States he's always there he's on
TV he's at many of Trump's press
briefings he's being interviewed all the
time and he is an actual doctor meaning
that the things he says are typically
true when they're within his area of
expertise which is infectious disease
that is very different than Donald Trump
but when foutch II was asked in an
interview a few weeks ago
why aren't you publicly contradicting
Trump when he tells his lies ouchy
essentially said this is my paraphrase
foul she said you know it's not
realistic for me to step in front of him
at the podium every time he says
something that's wrong and say no no no
and it sort of seems like vouch he
recognizes that his presence is more
important than contradicting Trump at
every opportunity and we've even seen
foul Chi in some moments express
exasperation visibly one of those
moments was when Donald Trump mentioned
the deep state during a press briefing
and doctor foul she literally facepalms
incredulous about what Donald Trump was
saying at a more recent press conference
doctor foul she was directly asked
here's what the president says about
hydroxychloroquine can you comment about
it and Trump literally did not allow
doctor foul Chi to answer the question
and foul she looked very uncomfortable
but finally doctor foul she has made it
clear that were it not for Donald
Trump's actions we might have been able
to save people and Donald Trump is
immediately signaling that he may be
preparing to fire doctor foul she let's
go through it step-by-step this is from
CNN now remember we have to have
realistic expectations about what
Anthony foul she will say foul she's not
going to insult Trump he's not going to
say Trump failed us but doctor foul she
admitted and this is something that
they've not yet been clear about doctor
foul she admits if we had taken this
more seriously earlier we would have
saved lives take a look at the video
from CNN the New York Times reported
yesterday that you and
the top officials wanted to recommend
social and physical distancing
guidelines to President Trump as far
back as the third week of February but
the administration didn't announce such
guidelines to the American public until
March 16th almost a month later why you
know Jake as I've said many times we
look at it from a pure health standpoint
we make a recommendation often the
recommendation is taken sometimes it's
not but we it is what it is we are where
we are right now do you think Alliance
could have been saved if social
distancing physical distancing
stay-at-home measures had started third
week of February instead of mid-march
you know Jake again it's the what would
have what could have it's very difficult
to go back and say that I mean obviously
you could logically say that if you had
a process that was ongoing and you
started mitigation earlier you could
have saved lives obviously no one is
going to deny that but what goes into
those kinds of decisions is is
complicated but you're right I mean
obviously if we had right from the very
beginning shut everything down it may
have been a little bit different but
there was a lot of pushback about
shutting things down back then do you
think lives could have been saved yes
they could have been it's doctor fowey
he uses non-confrontational language but
this is a big deal because Donald Trump
has been insisting and continues to
insist there was nothing he could
possibly have done differently there was
nothing he could possibly have done
earlier no matter what he had known had
he read those memos he didn't read no
matter what he did everything as soon as
it could have been done and nothing
could have been done differently
Trump has denied the notion that if he
had acted earlier lives would have been
saved
despite the reality that you know you
don't really need to be a doctor to
realize that that's not true
also important was that Anthony foul she
said we make recommendations the
recommendations aren't always taken for
Anthony foul she's temperament that is
him saying we told Trump and he ignored
us we can't expect doctor foul treat to
make direct attacks we can't
Specht him to behave like Trump does but
this is a doctor making it clear
recommendations were made they were not
followed if they had been followed we
would have fewer deaths right now but
remember on a per capita basis it's not
even close in South Korea South Korea's
population is smaller than ours but
importantly both countries had their
first cases right around February 20th
matter of hours separating the two on a
per capita basis our case rate is 1700
cases per million
theirs is 205 that's not an error 1,700
versus 205 as doctor foul she says the
heterogeneity of the population may be a
factor doesn't explain a 9x difference
moving early does and they moved early
our test rate is 8,500 per million there
is a 10,000 per million we have a 20%
lower test rate and of course that's now
bearing in mind that they were that high
much much earlier and it's reflected in
the death toll our death rate is 67 per
million South Korea's is 4 that's not an
error their death rate is 4 people per
million hours at 67 our death rate is
almost 17 times higher than South
Korea's now unfortunately Trump appears
to be signaling he may be ready to fire
doctor foul Chi after this statement
came out yesterday from doctor foul Chi
if we had moved earlier we could have
saved people Trump retweeted a tweet
from a lady named Diane Loraine who said
bouchy is now saying that had Trump
listened to the medical experts earlier
he could have saved more lives foul she
was telling people on February 29 that
there was nothing to worry about and it
posed no threat to the US public at
large
time to fire foul Chi Trump retweeting
that and adding that it is all fake news
there is very clearly little tolerance
for dissension in the ranks it seems dr.
pouchy may soon be fired by Donald Trump
I hope it doesn't happen if we do do if
we do lose doctor foul Qi it is going to
get even worse we will see if doctor
foul Qi is there today at the White
House coronavirus press briefing but it
is not looking good
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show follow me on instagram at david
pakman to see the start of my 20/20
bengali
plenty of time for gardening given that
I don't leave my house we'll take a
quick break and be back with much more
right after this this episode is
sponsored by blue chew one of the things
I make a priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and blue two can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for blue to calm blue
like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
ingredient as in Viagra and Cialis it
can be taken day or night even on a full
stomach since it's chewable it works
twice as fast as a pill whenever the
opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue two prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue
chew gum get your first shipment free
when you use our promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma n pages $5 shipping
that's blue2 dot-com promo code Pakman
to try it totally free blue chew is the
better cheaper faster choice and we
thank them for sponsoring the David
Pakman show